[Music]
hi Wesley thank you so much for joining
me how do you feel about being back here
in San Luis and competing in this chess
uh well I feel great I'm very thankful
to thank those jazz club for hosting
this event although of course you need
to have this event because it's
directing Phil's birthday and all the
tournaments got moved this year in
grantchester but uh I'm very glad to be
back actually it's only my second time
St Louis this year so uh I'm really
looking forward to it and it's great
that we have all American players you
know we have lots of young players and
you know to build companionship within
the country because
we're looking forward to it and uh
hopefully I can do well I'm also looking
forward to the ultimate moves and also
the
uh analysis sessions before the games uh
what is your favorite
um way of playing chess do you prefer
classical chess rapid blades which one
would you say it's is your favorite oh
well I'm trying to improve my classical
jazz I've been trying the entire year
with no success but uh chess has really
changed a lot compared to when I first
started 10 years ago so there's a lot
more online there's a lot more rapid in
Blitz
uh
I think it started
first because of course the world rapid
and Blitz and then it started because of
the branches to Rapid and Blitz
tournaments in 2015 and 2016.
um
I'm still trying to focus on classical
because in my opinion Blitz is not
really chess it's more about flagging or
like in the hell out of your opponent
but uh
in terms of money and sponsorship I
think it's more gearing towards faster
time controls interesting so classical
chess I I always thought maybe you like
rapid a little bit more but it's good it
seems have better thoughts so classical
chess is far harder and it takes a lot
longer it takes twice the amount uh with
driving on Blitz you can be pretty chill
pretty relaxed you don't really have to
do specific preparation
but the
yeah I mean Jeff is not supposed to be
easy so of course and this time around
you are here for chess 9lx Fisher random
how do you feel about this variant is it
your favorite variant and what did you
do particularly to prepare for this
tournament well the variant for sure is
very interesting uh it removes all
preparations there there are millions
and millions of chess games played
already so
there's very there's not as much
creativity as there used to be and also
with powerful computers you know you
have unfortunately you have to use it
but f950 is very interesting because
there's no way to prepare so you
basically
start playing by yourself on on move too
maybe that move one because everyone
analyzes but uh move three and uh if
you're interested my results on chess
960 have been very mixed uh it's been
very up and down I had good tournaments
and and but I remember there was an
online back in 2000. 20 where I did
decently you became a Fisher random
world champion one year a few years back
didn't you yeah 19 yeah yeah it was back
when it was a match format now Hikaru
has it so it's going to be very
interesting so I don't know remember
2019 I was just
in preparation for tournament I was
studying my opponent's games and
studying their styles
and it worked very well
um
but my results have been up and down uh
and
the time control also plays a lot of
factor because back in 2019 the time
control was longer here it's yeah so you
have 20 20 minutes with I believe 10
seconds increment or 20 plus 10 yeah
yeah so how do you feel about that time
control and how do you feel about the
fact that you only have 15 minutes
before knowing I mean you get 15 minutes
to get prepared for your next round yeah
it's interesting I mean I like the
of analyzing with other players but
maybe to be frank it's not really that
useful because you have very little time
and maybe sometimes just better to have
a clear head and focus on the game
because I remember that what Furious it
was doing the entire last year when when
he won the event so
that's interesting and is there a
particular
um exercise that you found effective to
improve your visualization skills
interests and maybe in 960 as well well
I'm probably not the best person to ask
that based on myself but I do some warm
up you know like analyzing difficult
positions
ah just just before uh again with very
limited time control it you have to pay
huge amount of attention to the club
but if if you have more time perhaps
analyzing your opponents and figuring
them out
I see final question Wesley uh how do
you feel who's the player that you're
looking the most forward to to playing
against in this tournament uh in this in
this field oh Gary everyone says Gary so
yeah yeah you've played against him
before right yeah he said check out
YouTube in 2016.
2016 my Blitz game against Gary but uh
uh Gary has always been uh
uh I've always been a big fan of Gary
because I remember back in 2000
I think year 2000 I was playing some key
distortment in the Philippines and the
prices were Gary Casper of books and
also his matches with that's where Robin
so I
never imagined that I would meet Gary in
person so I'm always a big admiration
for him and I feel amazing after
18 years out of retirement that he can
still play very decent and he's ready
he's ready for it
he's not gonna lose eight games in there
I think he's ready for it yeah but yeah
but irregardless you know he's he's a
living legend and uh
um
uh yeah and if primary was really
amazing like
okay it'd be interesting to see uh how
he would do against uh Magnus if they
were in the same era
but I'll also look forward of course too
playing against uh Fabiano and Hikaru
who've been doing very well recently so
big congratulations to him for doing
well in the World Cup
thank you very much Wesley and I wish
you good luck looking forward to seeing
you yes sir yeah I'm very excited also
when I wish Rick thinkfield a very happy
birthday looking forward to playing him
later
[Music]